eu me lembrei do dramaturgo e poeta
alemão bertold preste que é o de que a
gente é grande admirador do núcleo
bartolomeu que tem um poema em que ele
diz eu vivo em tempos sombrios o poema
se chama aos que vierem depois de nós e
no final ele diz a voz que vierem depois
de nós
olhar pra nós com indulgência avós que
estiver em tempos melhores que os nossos
olhar para nós com indulgência eu acho
que a gente vive em tempos sombrios
ainda tempos de luta lutar cotidiana
lutar diária grandes lutas pequenas
lutas e em tempos de luta em uma
sociedade em que você precisa ser mais
forte mais veloz mais alto ganhar mais
dinheiro e mais e dá mais é muito
difícil lutar sem sim duras e sem é ver
o que a gente vê acontecendo sem dor e
ser então esse foi o primeiro poema que
vou falar se chama dura ação e fala
sobre isso sobre lutar e tem a dureza
que se tem que ter porque realmente não
está fácil mas esse poema é sobre não
perder a ternura
não adianta esmurrar a ponta da faca
não adianta lutar como um guerreiro diz
parte exibir a cicatriz como prêmio da
guerra ser a pedra que estilhaçou o
vidro da janela o grito rosnar absoluta
beleza absoluta razão absoluta regra
absoluta certeza o mais perfeito
entendimento a precisão desses três
ouvido absoluto a nota certa pureza a
perfeição vinda de um ser imperfeito é
imperfeita uma mentira um arremedo uma
imitação mal feito ea rigidez à dureza
toda dedicação em tentar
consegui lá é o mais precioso tempo
perdido em tentar contemplar mas sou
forte sou vigas ou aço
assim sem viver é como me acho seguro
controlo retém não vou eu que reconheceu
que tem aqui sou subindo a escada que
desce desviando tecido que tece que vem
do bb na criança que cresce
indo dormir quando o sol aparece e assim
me quebro que assim me arrebento assim
continua fingindo e pretendendo a mim
sim
ser for quero ser rio ser fonte correr
fazer sustentável e minha presença
leveza do ser
quero brincar florescer coração quero os
meus pés em contato com o chão e se
machucar com a só passará sem ver se dá
certo confiar confiar e ri muito mais um
pouquinho chorar do lago para o rio do
rio para o mar
dissolver as duas paredes que construir
com músculos areia e cal e suavemente
tornar maleável
a dureza do metal retirar das flechas
palavras o veneno letal abrir mão do
sempre certo do sempre perfeito do ideal
é correr o risco de sint receber em meus
braços acolher abrir e quem sabe assim
com as armas no chão
poderei finalmente aceitar o perdão
poderei a quem levou a pedir perdão
poderei calmamente aceitar quem eu sou
quem eu fui quem virá e saber para onde
vão